there's something wrong with telling
boys and telling young men that they
should cry for the sake of crying or
that it's inherently a virtue to cry
it's not it's inherently a good thing to
bridle your emotions to moderate your
own instincts instead of just acting on
them and I would say some inherently
good thing to teach young men to be
vulnerable with the people they trust
and they love that's toxic masculinity
my clubs for closers let's talk about
toxic masculinity I think this is
something that's that's been tossed
around quite a bit in Cortez's talked
about this so it seems fitting I was the
vet this week and I'm hoping this one
thing the vet stuff always I think Joe
Rogan and Kevin Smith were talking with
us the dog stuff always gets me so
phlegm not going to be too emotional I
was at the vet this week everything's
kind of okay but it's been rough with
the chemo treatment again I appreciate
the the kind words of support but I was
there at this emergency vet on Saturday
and I was waiting there in the waiting
room there was this 15 year old girl who
was crying and it's one of those things
I will I will genuinely never forget
this girl's face I actually I feel
things really deeply I'm socially very
awkward people who probably met me
sometimes are surprised I can we do a
change my mind over the shows like me a
little bit more outgoing whereas my dad
was with me and he knows the right thing
to say this this girl was crying she was
very upset and I said hey yeah yeah
what's what's going on I should I had to
Brett brought in my 14 year old dog and
she had a seizure and she was she was
crying she couldn't even just tears
streaming down her face you know that's
that's kind of tough and talked about we
were kind of going through with with
with hopper and the cancer treatment and
I didn't know what to say I kind of just
just fizzled out and my dad saved it and
said like hey do you want do you want
some water he took some water from the
fridge there hey I'm buying because
those free water and she kind of laughed
she was wearing a sweater that said
Canada on it I think one of those roots
sweaters as a company and so we asked
her if she was from Canada she was from
upstate New York and she forgot about it
for little she stopped crying for a
little bit she was very awkward this
girl too
frizzy hair probably someone who was
very very close with her dog probably
the kind of person who maybe had a
deeper connection with her dog than most
people I know I had deeper connections
with animals as a kid sometimes in the
Abo's people because I didn't know how
to relate to them um and so I'm trying
to find a way to get into this again I'm
trying to keep my emotions in check when
we were leaving we were okay and as I
was to kind of give me an idea what this
looks like I'm trying to see if you can
see scope there's a wall divided and
there's a glass door and so there's a
little bit of a cutout where you know
you pay for your you pay for whatever
services rendered and I can see her on
the other side of this wall through a
glass door the fifteen-year-old girl at
this point she was she was sobbing but
after we spoke with her she was it
seemed a little bit better she was
looking things up on her phone a little
more talkative in the waiting room and I
sent my dad out with the crate to our
car we pulled the car around
and I saw her mom and there was no dad
there so I can see both sides of this
dividing wall and I saw her mom talking
to the vet and I overheard her saying
how does this work with a 14 15 year-old
girl does she you know holder and the
vet said well you know it depends if you
think she's most comfortable doing that
and it's one of those things where I'm
in this position where I can see
effectively that this girl's whole world
is about to become unglued and I didn't
sleep at all that night I all I could
see was her face all night long it was
unbelievably hard and I gathered myself
I walked through the the glass door one
of those saw the wall said hey really
love your sweater you know God bless
hope hope you have a good night she'd oh
thank you you know and she was she was
smiling I'm a I can't remem ate some
kind of a joke and walked out
that's what toxic masculinity is and let
me explain what that means we don't show
our emotions all the time we're all
constantly accused if you're not showing
emotions because of a toxically
masculine culture it's not because we're
afraid of being teased or because we're
afraid of feeling in that instance I
walked out to my car by the way with my
dad and I cried I was it was absolutely
heartbreaking but I needed in that
moment that wasn't going to help her
that's toxic masculine and even it was
just a laugh for 20 seconds before I
know she's gonna have to hold her 14
year old dog before they put it down why
would it matter why would I go out there
and try to be strong I know it sounds
silly for this fifteen-year-old girl
because it's even for 15 seconds I can
protect a girl like that from from pain
and it's the same thing with their
family members with their wives with
their daughters with their sisters this
is why men act the way that we do it's
because we love you it's because we want
to protect you we hate to see people and
pain we hate to see the people that we
love and pain that's toxic masculinity
that's like this I just I wanted to give
this girl a hug and I know I know I
can't because you know of course would
be inappropriate but I felt so bad for
her there was no dad president doesn't
mean that there wasn't a dad doesn't me
that she doesn't have a dad but it was
that much more heartbreaking again it's
this carnal this primal reactions
visceral reaction that a man will have
if there is a woman who is vulnerable
who is exposed and there is no man there
to help her that's toxic masculinity you
might say it's the damsel in distress
syndrome fine okay I'm okay with it
it's in our nature to protect and to
provide just as it's in your nature
women to nurture care for okay we want
to prevent pain for you at all costs and
by the way this is I understand this
ironically sometimes that leads to us
causing pain that we get so stressed out
over trying to provide to protect
whether it's work whether it's trying to
be strong emotionally that we end up
lashing out at those who we live to
provide for who we live to protect just
like women ironically end up suffocating
the people they love sometimes or
spoiling them which with children it's
in our nature and it needs to be rattled
that's toxic masculinity but I don't
think that it's a nature that should be
condemned just because it's a part of
our genetic makeup it would be
emotionally selfish
they'll be incredibly emotionally
selfish no I came back home that night
too I came back to my wife brought the
dogs in and she was obviously very where
everything was was fine but she was
obviously very worried and I made sure
that when I came in I had an even
even-keeled temper explained what went
what happened was were we gonna have to
give the dog antibiotics and once she
was settled about 30 minutes after that
she asked me said what what what's wrong
what's what's bothering you and that's
when I told her what I had experienced
with the 15 year old girl that they were
gonna put the dog down and at that point
in time because I made sure that my wife
was taken care of before myself that's
toxic masculinity by the way and that's
a biblical notion the idea of a steaming
others first of treating your wives and
your women is the best among you by the
way that wasn't in ideal when we talked
about where do we get morals from the
idea of mercy what it wasn't really
considered a virtue in a lot of
societies until modern Christendom the
idea of treating your wives as the best
among the idea of treating your wives
with love and I get it they're gonna
people will say well what about submit
to your husband's okay it talks about
men loving your wives that was actually
kind of unique when Christ came around
this is just me talking about my
worldview once I had made sure that my
wife was taken care of that I'd called
any any fears or anxieties she had I
told her about what happened and at that
point guess what it was fine for me to
be vulnerable with my wife it was fine
for me to shed a tear and explain
something that was deeply impactful and
hurtful and my wife would never condemn
me for it and that's because we have an
open complementary relationship where we
understand each other's needs and do our
best to meet them as members of the
opposite sex that's toxic masculinity
this idea that men just by the way the
idea that expressing Jordan Peterson's
talk about this just expressing emotions
is somehow inherently helpful it's not
true maybe there's examples right there
you know how I felt when I saw that 15
year old girl I wanted to cry I felt
terrible I wanted I wanted to go into
hysterics oh you don't think men feel
that of course would it help her no it
would be selfish when I came home it was
late I was tired I felt this cold coming
down or flu whatever the hell it is
Ebola czar Ebola SARS what is
our SARS what is it guys we had Zika
Zeke was a thing swine sexy flu you
don't think I would love to come here oh
my gosh you wouldn't believe the night I
had but that would be emotionally
selfish and so I ensured that I came in
it's okay sweetheart how are you let me
explain this to you everything's okay I
love you are you secure all right here's
an emotional need that I have right now
when she asked there's an appropriate
time to express emotion and it's not
becoming of a young man to do that
there's nothing wrong with men crying
okay there's something wrong with
telling boys and telling young men that
they should cry for the sake of crying
or that it's inherently
a virtue to cry it's not it's inherently
a good thing to bridle your emotions to
moderate your own instincts instead of
just acting on them and I would say it's
an inherently good thing to teach young
men to be vulnerable with the people
they trust and they love like their
wives like their families that's toxic
masculinity there's this idea that
people talk about quite a bit as though
men either have to live into this
archetype of big dumb jock or the
sensitive artistic type who cries you
realize it's a very new thing look at
the readings of Teddy Roosevelt or even
Abraham Lincoln these were people who
were artistic these were people who
often were musically inclined people who
would who would paint people who would
write poetry and then they were
incredibly intelligent and physically
robust you were not complete you were
not considered a complete man unless all
of these facets made up your masculinity
that's toxic masculinity it broke apart
really with modern progressive feminism
I hate to beat a dead horse here that's
where we really separated people with a
sexual revolution and honestly it just
made it easier for scumbags to get laid
let's be honest that one's not working
out really well for women the original
term I've talked about this before I'll
leave you with this was you've heard
this you've heard its expression jack of
all trades master of none
it was originally jack of all trades
master of one meaning you were expected
to be a jack of all trades adequate
passable in all facets of life and to be
a master of one domain that's what would
make a truly great person a truly great
great artist truly great at anything but
that's what makes a truly great man as
well
that's when we talk about toxic
masculinity and we throw the baby out
with the bathwater we're throwing out
everything is created modern medicine
this Western civilization that has
served protected and provided for women
throughout centuries men want to do that
that's toxic masculinity we want to
provide free we want to protect you
that's toxic masculinity and sometimes
it comes with some [ __ ] that you don't
want that's what happens but we condemn
and you take this is what worries me too
is this generation of boys that we have
now going out there but you know you've
talked we've talked about in cells
that's a pretty small microcosm of it
but imagine an entire generation now
really we're going on two generations of
boys who've been told that all of their
instincts all their hardwiring is wrong
and toxic they're going to be afraid to
be who they are we can't how do you how
do you juxtapose that where you say hey
yeah top masculine it's toxic
masculinity this idea that you don't
want to try this idea that you want to
be tough this idea that you want to be
athletic this idea that you want to be
great this ideally you want to be
competitive that's toxic don't don't
engage any of those instincts that you
have by the way keep it real there's no
what kind of a conflicted message that
is to send young men and a moment of
there's some women watch and it's
particularly some some young feminist
women who maybe haven't appeared behind
the curtain who maybe haven't understood
what it is it makes young men tick we
love we care and we are just as
emotional and we don't act on it because
we love you
that's toxic masculinity Here I am
drinking from my mug in a button-down
how often do you see this never so do me
a favor and yourself click one of these
videos playing in one of these boxes
here or a subscribe hit a notification
bell also because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot if you really
want to support the show join my club if
you don't then there's no helping you